the stock market dropped precipitously
yesterday we'll give you all of the
analysis plus Quentin Tarantino is now
under fire for apparently choking uma
Thurman or something we'll discuss that
and Justin Trudeau proves that he is
basically a human mop I am Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
I have so many fantastic insults lined
up for Justin Trudeau today and I cannot
wait to use them I mean they just have a
whole pile of them just lined up before
me you can't actually see them they're
just off-screen but they are spectacular
we'll get to Justin Trudeau the me2
movement may be losing some of its some
of its luster but first we're going to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Birch gold so if you look at the stock
market today and yesterday and Friday
you might be thinking now is a good time
for me to be a little diversified and I
have most of my assets in the stock
market but I do have a significant
portion of my assets in precious metals
the reason being that you never know
when the government is going to inflate
the currency you don't know when the
stock market is going to crash you don't
know and that means that you ought to be
hedging your bets at least a little bit
and that's where my friends at Birch
gold that come in Birch gold group has a
long-standing track record of continued
success with thousands of satisfied
clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group right now you receive a
free information kit on physical
precious metals this comprehensive 16
page kit shows how gold and silver can
protect your savings and I can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds and into a precious metals IRA to
get that no-cost no-obligation kit go to
birchgold.com slash Bennett's
birchgold.com slash pin again they're
the folks that I trust with precious
metals investing birchgold.com slash
menus that slash Ben so that they know
that we sent you when the economy's
volatile it's not necessarily a bad
thing to have some your money in
precious metals birchgold.com slash
banner okay so speaking of the economy
the stock market dropped a thousand
points yesterday it had gone all the way
down sixteen hundred points yesterday
that followed a six hundred sixty-six
point drop on Friday today the stock
market is basically balancing around its
last I checked it's up by fifty six
points or so but you never know on days
like this you really don't know until
about three pm like late in the
afternoon you're gonna find out when the
stock market basically get close to
closing and people decide where they
want to finish their portfolio for the
day if there's a major sell-off at the
end of the day now everyone is going
nuts about this oh my god is the single
largest stock market drop in the history
of the United States in terms of peer
points well who cares about peer points
that's stupid that's like saying that
the GDP every year in the United States
goes up in peer dollar amounts that's
true in terms of percentage amounts
that's not necessarily the case in any
significant order
and that's the case with regard to the
stock market drop just because the stock
market dropped fifteen hundred points at
one point it was about a 3% 4% drop
yesterday that is not even close to the
top 25 stock market drops of all time
some people who are saying this was the
end of the world are stupid by the same
token now president Trump I've been
saying this for literally his entire
presidency the President of the United
States when he goes out and he uses the
stock market increase as an indicator of
economic health I said this well Obama
was president I've been consistent in
saying it well Trump was president the
stock market is not a good reflection of
the underlying economic fundamentals
plus the stock market is not the
responsibility of anyone presidents the
idea that President Trump came into
office and therefore he is responsible
solely for stock market increases and
decreases is stupid I said the same
thing about President Obama so I've been
entirely consistent on this point
another thing to know when you see
headlines saying that trillions of
dollars wiped out and wealth billions of
dollars wiped out and wealth Nautilus
from one of the people who actually sold
right so if you have a 401 K your 401 K
is worth less than it is than it was
yesterday at the beginning of the day
sure that's true if you tried to sell it
it would be worth less but are you
selling your 401 K today you have to
cash out today if you're not cashing out
today the answer is you lost zero money
this is why Warren Buffett was famous
for saying things like during the 2008
crash people would say well your entire
portfolio you lost billions and billions
of dollars buffle to tell you well no I
didn't I didn't sell and lose anything
Oh in the real estate market goes down
if you don't sell your house he didn't
lose any money the value of your house
may have gone down meaning if you sold
your house what would it be worth today
but if you're not selling your house
today what do you care and went with
consequently when the stock market rises
when they say Jeff Bezos made a billion
dollars in a day no he didn't even sell
any of his stock I mean the value of his
stock went up so presumably if he tried
to sell in stock the value would be
higher but if you're not buying and
you're not selling then you're not
winning or you're not you're not losing
money or gaining money it's just the the
facts of life there folks the only
people who may have lost money yesterday
without actively selling are people who
are on what are called margin calls
people who have margin accounts of the
brokerage firm where they're basically
borrowing money from their stock broker
in order to buy stock and if they if the
stock market goes down too much then the
stock broker goes back to the person
with the margin account and forces them
to pay up some more money to buy more
stock to keep the margins up to shape
but that's relatively rare almost there
professional investor most people do not
have margin accounts so is it the
the world no it's not the end of the
world and it's not just me saying this
the New York Times is saying this can
there are times which has an interest in
putting forward the notion that Donald
Trump is leading to economic collapse
Neil Irwin over at the New York Times
has ignore the stock market the
underlying economy it looks fine he says
what is the stock market telling us with
its a precipitous drop over the last
several days in all likelihood not much
of anything that's because the stock
market though crucial in the long run
for individuals accumulating wealth and
companies raising capital in so erratic
as to be useless in providing
information about the sort of the
short-run the eight point five percent
drop in the sp500 could signify the
onset of a global recession it could
also mean that some trading algorithms
at a big hedge fund collided in weird
ways before what really matters the
well-being of the economy look first two
fundamental economic data second looks
at bond market and other financial
market indicators that are more reliable
measures of investor expectations than
stock prices basically there was a
theory going around over the last few
days if the reason the stock market had
a drop is because number one the wage
data was goods meaning the wage data
went up and so that meant the profit
margins and companies were going down
some people sold some stock as a
possibility number one possibility
number two is there were some signals
from the Fed the interest rates were
going to rise and that would make the
lines of credit a little bit harder to
get and that means that the stock market
is going to drop a little bit bond
yields I guess where we're up and so the
stock market went down sometimes in bond
yields go up the stock market goes up in
any case here's what Neil Irwin says
since there's good news on both fronts
as both points to a global economy that
will continue growing steadily in the
months and years ahead perhaps of
inflation that is a bit higher than in
the recent past this contrast is market
sell-offs with drops in 2011 2015 and
2016 which coincided with pessimistic
signals in both economic data and the
bond market the stock market can when
looked at in concert with these other
indicators provide some useful insight
right now it appears to be more noise
and then signal and he says the economic
date has been solid in recent weeks on
Friday the Labor Department reported the
u.s. added 200,000 jobs in January the
Federal Reserve Bank of Atlanta says
there they are going to they're looking
at a four percent annual increase of
economic expansion which is a major
number that was the number that Trump
promised and people were skeptical he
was going to get of course there's
plenty of statistical errors built into
these numbers they may turn out to be
incorrect but the bond market is looking
optimistic about the future prices
suggest the continued growth without
inflationary overheating is the most
likely future the stock market is lost
on ground since the start of the year
because of the sell-off on Monday but
the yield on ten-year Treasury bonds is
up in that span from 2.4 percent
to 2.75% which thinks that bond
investors think steady recovery will
allow the Federal Reserve to raise
interest rates gradually so in other
words this is just a market correction
okay now it may take a few months for
the stock market to go back up to what
it was but the idea that we are in a
full-scale economic collapse is really
stupid there's no evidence to that
effect now maybe that's what it turns
out to be but we haven't seen that and
we haven't seen any underlying
fundamentals that would suggest that at
this point this is why it's so dumb for
commentators to blame or credit the
stock market for a particular president
so Sean Hannity he's a good guy but like
this is so dumb yesterday he blame him
to the plunge in the Dow on Barak Obama
who has not been president since last I
checked January of 2017 it is now for
those who missed in February 2018 but I
guess that if Obama can blame Bush then
Kennedy can blame Obama here's Sean
going after going after Barack Obama for
the Dow plunging a year and a half after
he left office because the Obama economy
was so weak all of these years we had
just artificially cheap money now what's
cheap month cheap money cheap money is
when you can borrow at ridiculously low
rates the era of cheap money at some
point has to come to an end okay so he's
not completely but Sean isn't completely
wrong about this but it's not quite that
simple the fact is that they're not
looking at tremendous inflation rates
right now I agree with his analysis of
the stock market under Obama but that
wouldn't explain why the stock market
has continued to rise under President
Trump even as the money supply tightens
because the Fed has been raising rates
gradually in any case you know the stock
market has very little to do with
politics in the end it has a lot more to
do with confidence in particular
companies people don't buy in I mean you
buy indices of your 401 K but most
people don't buy indices most people buy
certain stocks right they're picking a
certain bundle of stocks high-risk
stocks low-risk stocks here's the deal
folks you want to make money in the
stock market take a little bit of money
invest in the stock market every month
and just leave it there just leave it
there forever right until you need it
okay if you if you did this and you've
been doing this for your entire life and
when the stock market goes down like
this month I'm excited I do this every
month this month I'm excited I just got
a discount on stocks I get to buy a
bunch of them all right next month
presumably on the stock market goes up I
will buy again and there's a good way to
incrementally increase your portfolio
whether the stock market goes up or
whether the stock market
goes down but everybody who's panicked
when the stock market takes a dip like
this and oh we must need major
government intervention unless there is
a serious underlying economic problem
like there was in 2008 government
intervention is usually unnecessary and
even more so counterproductive okay so
in just a second I'm going to talk about
gary-oke Quentin Tarantino and Justin
Trudeau and the insanity of the
feminists left and the me2 movement and
what they're doing cuz it really is
getting kind of crazy out there first I
want to say thank you for sponsors are
over at thrive market so you want to eat
healthy but you don't want to go over to
Whole Foods and deal with all the
Schmucks in the forum Priuses in the
Toyota Priuses who are driving around
with their bumper stickers that say save
the whales and clogging up the parking
lots they don't know how to drive with
their silent killer Priya says you don't
want to do that right you know want to
go to one of these overpriced organic
food markets instead what you want to do
is go to thrive market it's an online
grocer with a mission to make healthy
living affordable and accessible to
everybody they cut out the middleman for
the first time in history can purchase
premium non-gmo organic products at
wholesale prices it's all delivered to
your door plus you can organize the
products by Avera by a high number of
certain indicators that you're looking
for so they have a kosher thing for me
so that's great I can get a bunch of
products that I know are kosher from
thrive market in one click of a button
you can sort thrive markets catalog by
90 values based on your dietary needs
from vegans gluten-free from paleo to
non-gmo and more they have a hyper
curated catalog so you might find 1500
man butters at your local health store
and they'll all be really expensive but
it thrived they've narrowed it down to
three or four almond butters they are
the best and you know they're sourced
from the best of the best it's not just
foods by the way it supplements protein
powders all the stuff that you're gonna
use if you're working out you can get
them at 50% off retail so everything is
a lot less expensive than if you were to
go to that organic food market bull your
way through all of the people with seven
nose-rings and suddenly and make your
way to the counter with your protein
powder that's 50% overpriced instead you
can go to thrive market for my listeners
my friends at thrive market are offering
you 60 bucks of free groceries pretty
awesome deal plus free shipping and a
30-day free trial that is an incredible
deal keep in mind thrive markets prices
are already 25 to 50 percent off retail
and now they're offering an extra 60
bucks of free groceries so again 60
bucks of free groceries plus free
shipping and a 30-day free trial which
is an amazing feeling to go thrive
market calm / Shapiro's thrive market
calm / appear and you get your instant
60 bucks off
free groceries which is again that's a
lot of money they're giving you right
off the top thrive market calm slash
appear Oh eat healthy eat fresh and do
it from the comfort of your own home
without having to go to one of these
organic food markets that's filled with
obnoxious people's if I have not made
that clear I hate going to Whole Foods I
mean it says this is why I thrive market
is great thrive market calm slash appear
Oh check it out get your instant 60
bucks of free groceries and that 30 day
free trial when you slash capiro you'll
let them know as well that we sent you
okay so meanwhile the feminist movement
the me2 movement you know there was talk
about whether they were going off the
rails apparently they have gone
full-scale off the rails we begin today
with Justin Trudeau suffice it to say
that Justin Trudeau is Owen Wilson from
Meet the Parents except without the
woodworking skill Justin Trudeau is one
of the more obnoxious sycophantic
ridiculous idiotic get teenage girls in
a boy's body that I've ever seen I mean
it's just it's insane the guy's the only
famous because his dad was Gary Trudeau
his previous life what did he do in his
previous career I can't remember whose
something ridiculous it was like he was
a grocery check or something dumb
he's did not the grocery checkers are
done but it's not really a qualification
for being Prime Minister of Canada he is
his career before that let's see in 2009
he was appointed to the Liberal Party's
a critic for youth and multiculturalism
in 2011 here's a point that is critic
for secondary education he was a he grew
he worked as a teacher in Vancouver he
completed one year of an engineering
program one year and then one year of a
master's program in environmental
geography and and he worked in and he
was an athlete or something and so
there's a bunch of pictures of the shirt
off and apparently this makes the ladies
swoon or some such nonsense in any case
Justin Trudeau was on camera and he said
several silly things on camera here is
one of the silly things that he said on
camera he was asked someone wanted to
ask him a question about mankind the
person asking the question happened to
be a female student like a woman so
Justin Trudeau manse plains to her that
she shouldn't use the word mankind for
oh my goodness watch this watch this
more on maternal love is the love that's
going to change the future of mankind so
we'd like you to look we would like to
say people kind
not necessarily mankind what the f is
wrong with this guy
people kind do you mean humankind like
an actual word people kind as Jack
Handey once said mankind is made up with
two words man can end you don't know
what either of them means that's why
mankind is so mysterious but still like
justin justin trudeau my god the man is
if the song imagine could take human
form and then eat a tide pod that would
be justin trudeau
he is do you understand the stupidity of
this first of all the word mankind comes
from humankind it is just a shortened
version of version of humankind is there
any woman on earth who's serious about
feeling offended when people say mankind
of course mankind includes women hey
we're the species of man it doesn't mean
we are a species only of men hahaha
oh the levels of stupidity but this is
supposed to be empowering for women
honestly if you're a woman and you feel
empowered because a man just explained
mansplain to a woman that you can't use
the word mankind if that makes you feel
more feminist because justin trudeau
just told a female student who's talking
about the power of motherly love that
she shouldn't use the word mankind that
makes you feel like a real feminist let
me suggest that something is wrong with
you in the head doesn't the only dumb
thing that Justin Trudeau said yesterday
Justin Trudeau also compared Isis
terrorists apparently to immigrants from
Vietnam Greece and Italy which makes
perfect sense first of all the fact that
one of the reasons Canada is successful
as a country is because we have been
open to people fleeing persecution
fleeing war zones looking for a better
life for themselves and their kids when
we welcomed in waves of refugees whether
it was the smiley refugees in the early
70s whether it was the Vietnamese boat
people in the early 80s whether it was
people said fleeing the devastation of
the Second World War from southern
Europe in the 50s and 60s the Italian
communities the Greek communities the
the Portuguese communities and others
okay so here's the problem with this
here the question that he was asked here
the question that led to him saying all
of this was a question about letting in
people who could be affiliated with Isis
ranks here the guy asked him a question
and it said how are you going to protect
future Canadians like my young daughter
10 15 20 years from now when you're
letting in people with an ideology that
just does not conformed
what we're doing here and then Trudeau
immediately lumped in a bunch of people
who may be sympathetic to terrorists
with all the other refugees coming in
from all the other countries he doesn't
say we're going to ideologically screen
people which would be the proper answer
instead he says this because Justin
Trudeau must have been dropped on his
head as a baby but it's okay because he
comes from a famous family lest it be
said that America is stupid for electing
President Trump or for electing george w
bush or for electing kennedy's or legacy
families Canadians before you get on
your high horse about this this is your
Prime Minister guys hey yeah just good
call good call okay so if this is the
new feminist movement Justin Trudeau
lecturing women about using the word
mankind that was not the end of the
stupidity the New York Times ran a piece
yesterday that included a song okay the
person who who did this song and and
then they ran the entire lyric as an
op-ed and then the name of the woman is
Emily Lin she voices Eric trump Ivanka
Trump Karen pence Nancy Pelosi and Betsy
DeVos on stephen colbert's our cartoon
president of course she does and she did
a song about how hard it is to date okay
I just want to play some of this because
if you want to date this woman you are
out of your mind maybe it's hard for you
to her today because she's a crazy
person because here's what she hears her
stupid song hey hey have you been
reading the news well I'd really like to
hear about your views this movements
gotten just a touch hand well change
your only happens after taking a stand
would you ever want to come and what did
you smoke why wouldn't you want to date
this I don't understand why can't she
get a date guys like all the guy said
there was I think maybe the movements
gotten a touch out of hand and then she
goes crazy and says she's been triggered
and you need to join the resistance and
she says have you been reading the news
maybe I can order a drink cuz you're at
a bar okay what's wrong with these
people and then you wonder why you can't
my goodness I love this it continued
along these lines by the way this crazy
lady playing her playing her ukulele
like Michael Noel's and and it continues
she says this is one she says this guy's
garbage he's clearly a foe why cuz he
said he wanted order a drink maybe she
want to come see his band yeah that's
sexual predation now it continued along
these lines by the way she says you see
we're victims of systemic above systemic
oppression when the guy says yeah but
thank God we're in a time of progression
and then she says your deflection as a
microaggression and the guy says I
didn't mean it please don't be mad and
she said all buddy do you have more to
add he said hashtag not all men are that
bad and then she says what did you K
that's not okay I'm feeling triggered in
every which way
doesn't that plant look great go ahead
masturbate while I call Ronan Farrow to
break up the state singing ooh men are
toxic oh why on earth am i straight why
on earth are you are you not in the same
asylum I mean my goodness the guy
legitimate ly says in your little
made-up mind right this did this
conversation never happened this is in
your little made-up mind right that
we're in a time of progress for women
true but that's a microaggression then
he says he didn't mean it he backs off
and then she said and then he says that
not all men are bad and then she says
that that's a microaggression he's just
like Harvey Weinstein and then there's
another one where she says so I've
assumed you've roofied my beer and the
guy says man that joke is way too severe
and she said well we've had a terrible
year and he says I swear I sympathize
with your plight and should how your
straight cisgendered man who is white
and man says well can I say anything
right and she's what did you say that's
not okay my cat person doesn't exist
anyway unless it's my cat that's it I'll
marry my cat he wouldn't hurt me because
he's not like that and then the cat says
I can't consent she says fair enough
okay maybe the
problem here is that oh my goodness okay
so there are no more words than words
this was on the op-ed page of the New
York Times so maybe she's joking but
it's not clear that she's completely
joking about herself it seems like she's
just treating men like men are all crazy
so that's that's just awesome it was
called the dating blues hashtag me too
that's what the actual name of the piece
was so well done New York Times okay
that wasn't the the end of stupidity so
but you want to talk about where me too
should be useful so Quentin Tarantino
was caught on audio years ago saying to
Howard Stern that he thought Roman
Polanski had not raped a
thirteen-year-old girl it is impossible
for a thirteen-year-old girl to consent
the girl was roofied and draw she was
drugged and then she was given alcohol
and then she was anally raped apparently
by Roman Polanski back when she was 13
years old back in the 1970s now to be
fair Whoopi Goldberg's had the same
thing you're about to hear Clinton
Tarantino say and she has a spot on the
view but she's a lady so I guess she's
allowed to say that here's Quentin
Tarantino saying something truly awful
but that's not why he's in trouble today
guilty of having sex with a minor
no that was not the case at all she
wanted to have it dated the guy and
found out William by the way we're
talking about America's morals we're not
talking about the morals in Europe and
everything with a thirteen-year-old girl
and you're in a grown man you know that
that's wrong because she was down with
it okay so so this is not what he's in
trouble for right if he'd been in
trouble for this
that would made sense like years ago
when he actually said it but that's not
actually why Quentin Tarantino's in
trouble Quentin Tarantino is in trouble
because there is an article from Maureen
Dowd in which Huma Thurmond accuses
Clinton Tarantino of making her drive a
car yes really in America we're so
sexist we force women to drive cars as
opposed to Saudi Arabia where we don't
let women track where men don't let
women drive cars so I want to tell you
the whole story because I am NOT a
quittin Tarantino fan I'm not quittin
Turrentine or defender I mean you can
hear from that clip I think Quentin
Tarantino's kind of trash when I say
kind of trash I mean I think that he's
actually trash but the extension of the
meat to
movement out to things that the me to
move it was not meant to cover grows a
pace and is pretty nuts and I'm gonna
talk about that in just a second first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at oh yes man crates so I'm always
very excited to talk about man Craig
because man crates calm they get you the
best gifts it's the only place to find
awesome gifts that guys love so
Valentine's Day is coming up ladies I've
talked a lot about what men should get
for you right that's why we talk about
1-800 flowers but here's what you can
get for your man you can get him a man
crate because man crates calms makes the
perfect gift we're talking about
classics like the NFL bar were crate the
whiskey appreciation crate the jerky
heart or the salami bouquet right and
then brings you flowers ladies you can
get your man a salami or salami bouquet
in return and who'll appreciate it a lot
more than flowers they have all of these
curated gifts and they come in the crate
with a crowbar with a person with it
with a with an engraved crowbar and you
actually take the crowbar and you pry
open the crate or it comes in an ammo
box that's why I got my poker chips they
also have some pretty new gifts that are
pretty awesome I just got a guitar with
my name engraved on it
from man crates calm now do I play
guitar absolutely not of course I don't
play guitar but I'm gonna carry it
around and look really brooding and then
my wife is gonna be totally into it that
is the plan that's why men love man
Christ because the gifts are just
incredible they're thousands of
five-star reviews every gift comes with
a complete satisfaction guarantee go to
man crates calm slash pen you get five
percent off that discount is only
available here so get five percent off
right now at man crates calm slash Bend
that is man crates calm slash Ben it is
spectacular
again you pry open that wooden crate
with the included crowbar all the gifts
are just great I've had a couple of them
and they're always fun and I promise you
your guys going to enjoy it too man
crates calm slash been pretty fantastic
ok so back to Quentin Tarantino so
Quentin Tarantino is not under fire for
having made the grave mistake of
defending Roman Polanski raping a
thirteen-year-old girl like ten years
ago right if you're under fire for that
then Whoopi Goldberg would also have to
lose her job because she would not be
part of the meeting movement instead
he's under fire because there was a New
York Times article about uma Thurman and
her assault at the hands of Harvey
Weinstein right and this and this
article was not just about Emma Thurman
it was also about Quentin Tarantino so
in the article Tarantino is accused of a
disturbing car crash so basically in the
making of Kill Bill there was a there's
a scene where uma Thurman is driving and
apparently uma Thurman is a bad driver
and he wanted her to drive the car and
she did not want to drive the car and
they took the whole shoot to drive the
car and finally he said her to listen
just it's an easy drive you can drive
the car and naturally she swerved and
crashed into a tree and she was hurt and
had to go to the hospital and Tarantino
talks about it he says listen you know
it was not it was not a hard drive I
didn't bully her into it she's a fully
capable woman of saying no you know I
was annoyed but it wasn't like I was I
was forcing her to do it I driven it
myself it was a mistake right and then
he released the tape and the tape was
included in the New York Times piece
okay so he's getting ripped up for that
for saying to his actress maybe you
should drive this car when that was part
of the script when it's not exactly a
stunt driving a car like 30 miles an
hour it's so funny they say like oh he
made her drive 30 to 40 miles an hour
okay 30 40 miles an hour's what you're
driving in a school zone basically I
guess you're not supposed to drive that
fast in a school zone it's how fast
you're not supposed to drive into school
to him but it is in four commercial
districts that is the speed limit so
we're not talking about gunning it to 80
miles an hour and him making them with
Herman do it and then there and then
Huma Thurmond complained because in one
seat Aparo in one scene apparently he
should the Quentin Tarantino personally
choked her while the camera was on
another he spit on her while the camera
was on and so he explains why all of
that happened and what he says is listen
this was part of the movie right part of
the movie and if you ever seen Kill Bill
Kill Bill is an insanely violent movie
it's one of most violent movies ever
made the whole thing is a revenge flick
or revenge fantasy flick in which people
have limbs cut off in which blood is
everywhere
there's a scene where uma Thurman takes
out with 50 guys there's another scene
where she kills him she kills a mother I
mean she's like it's she has a baby
carved out of her I mean like it's it's
really egregious the movie it's it's
it's it's a violent porn flick and
that's what Tarantino does Tarantino's a
director I've always disliked I've
always thought the Quentin Tarantino is
basically a snuff film director who
makes a few scenes that are really great
like the opening scene and glorious
bastards is fantastic but he can't
sustain anything longer than 12 minutes
of interest but here is here's what he
says about the about the spitting and
the choking so in the article this
Deadline Hollywood interview and Quentin
Tarantino in this article
uma complains about
choked by you in a scene he says let me
address that according to Huma you know
they're not quotes around that Ummah
didn't share that with maureen dowd
brains out interview two other people on
the side who mentioned it to her if you
notice all that choking and spitting
stuff is not in quotes from uma it's
part of Maureen Dowd's prose for some
reason there's a lot of hay being made
out of this which I don't understand at
all you seen movies where somebody spits
in somebody's face and Deadline
Hollywood says many his well that's what
that was the scene where somebody spits
in somebody's face I can't explain why I
did it exactly but my question is what's
the effing problem and he's sort of
right it's in the script that she has
spit on right and then he explains why
he personally spit on her right so piss
so he said he says we've all seen movies
where people get spit in the face I'm
assuming if it was a two shot and
Michael Madsen spat in her face that
probably wouldn't be an issue but that
wasn't the shot the shot was Michael
Madsen had snuff juice and he seems spit
out a stream of snuff just got to whom
his face on the ground and he had hit
her naturally I did it who else should
do it a grip one I didn't trust Michael
Madsen because I didn't know where the
spits gonna go if Michael Madsen does it
I talked to him and I said look I've got
to come in and commit to doing this to
you we even had a thing that we were
gonna try and do with a plunger in some
water but if you had snuffed used to
water it didn't look right it didn't
look like spit when I hit her when he
tried that it needs to be a mix of
saliva in the brown juice so I asked him
I said I think I need to do it I'll only
do it twice at the most three times but
I can't have you laying here getting
spit on again and again because someone
else is messing it up by missing it's
hard to spit on people as it turns out
so apparently Quentin Teena Tarantino
fancies himself a a spit expert right
he's a special league or odd expect or
raging toward the Gaston from Beauty and
the Beast but in any case he says they
didn't trust Michael Madsen with this
kind of intricate work of spitting an
uma thurman's face so he did it himself
and he says I'm not gonna have a grip to
it because the grips gonna be
intimidated he'll screw it up so they
did three takes and Huma said if you
really need a fourth one go ahead and do
a fourth one so then in other words
allah consented to this because she's an
actress and actresses do all sorts of
stuff in films that she did many things
in these movies that wouldn't probably
not be pleasant to experience how about
the choking so here's what tarantino
says he says in the case of the choking
when gogo who's Chiaki Kuriyama
throws her chained ball at the bride and
the chain wraps around her neck and then
she's getting choked by it frankly I
wasn't sure how we were gonna shoot that
scene wrap a chain around the neck you
got to see the choking I was assuming it
than when we did it we would maybe have
a pole behind who mother the chain would
be wrapped around so wouldn't be seen by
the camera at least for the wide shot
but then it was in my suggestions just
wrap the thing around her neck and choke
her not forever not for a long time but
it's not gonna look right I can act all
straggly but if you want to get my face
right
it's yours to come to my eye then you
kind of need to choke me right so
zuma-zuma Thurman suggestion and say did
it again with Diane Kruger because it
worked so well in Kill Bill he says that
when he did inglourious basterds
he went to Diane Kruger and said look
I've got to strangle you it was just a
guy with his hands on your neck not
putting any kind of pressure and you're
doing this wiggling death-rattle it
looks like a normal movie strangulation
it looks movie ish but you're not gonna
get the blood vessels bulging or the
eyes filling it with tears you're not
gonna get the sense of panic that
happens when your air is cut off what
I'd like to do with your permission is
just commit to choking you with my hands
in a close-up will do it for 30 seconds
or so and then I stop if we need to do a
second time we will after that that's it
are you down to committing to it so we
can get a really good look it'll be
twice and only for this amount of time
and the stunt guy was monitoring the
whole thing Diane said yeah sure she
even said on film on an interview is a
strange request by that point I trusted
Quentin Tarantino so much that sure we
did our two times and then like uma with
the spitting spitting thing Diane said
okay if you need it do it once more you
can this is an issue of me asking the
actress can we do this to get a
realistic effect she agreed with it she
knew it would look good she trusted me
to do it I would ask the same thing with
a guy in fact I would probably be more
insistent with a guy so everybody's like
all over Quentin Tarantino because he
asked actresses and they said yes if
they didn't want to do it they could say
no if they wanted to do it a different
way they could say no they all have
agents these are all actresses who make
millions of dollars okay so there are
lots of reasons to dislike Quentin
Tarantino there lots of reasons to think
that his films are fetishistic and
violent nasty toward women I think that
a huge percentage of them are I don't
like Quentin Tarantino's work I think
the hateful eight is one of the worst
movies ever made I think there's there's
plenty about Quentin I think Pulp
Fiction is wildly overrated by the way
the idea that that men are abused in
violence here also in his movies is
obviously true I mean men get the worst
of it in his movies but the idea that
that Tarantino did something truly
terrible by asking these actresses if he
could do it himself because you want it
to be exactly right you know directors
are weird maybe this is a fetish of his
but if the actress said yes I don't
really see the major problem call me
crazy but I don't see the problem right
there there are lots of the in a movie
Jimmy Cagney smashes a woman in the face
of the grapefruit it's one of those
famous scenes in movie history he does
it as a gangster is that female abuse
Jessica Chastain seems to think yes by
the way Jessica Chastain the actress she
came forward and she said do we really
need more movies where a women is shown
being harmed to show that she's strong
in overcoming that harm it's like well
yes or no
because that's every movie ever made
whether it's with a girl or a guy
there's not a movie that is made
particularly an action flick where a man
or a woman doesn't undergo some kind of
trauma and then have to overcome that
trauma that's called the hero's journey
it's part of every single story ever so
yes now does that mean that we have to
be graphic about it I think not right
I'm a fan of movies where we weren't
graphic about these things does it have
to be something over-the-top I don't
think so it's why I don't like
Tarantino's films but the idea that we
have to change the entire storytelling
mechanism when a woman consents to be in
a movie for millions of dollars and then
makes her celebrity and her fame off of
doing these movies with her consent
again I'm failing to understand how it
is that consent is the final value if
you consent to something and then a
third party doesn't like it it's kind of
weird how this works now okay so as we
continue we're gonna talk about more on
memo gate we're gonna talk about what
looks like an admission against interest
from a Devin Nunez we're also going to
talk about you know what it is they're
really they're there and the malfeasance
of the media and also about the Moller
investigation first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at the business
wars podcast so this is a brand new
podcast and it is fantastic it's from
wondering the basic premise of the
business wars podcast is that everyday
business is at war blue chips versus
disruptors American Giants versus
Chinese competition founders against
corporate raiders sometimes the prize is
your wallet sometimes it's your
attention and sometimes it's just the
fun of beating it the other guy so this
podcast about these battles between
corporations how some businesses beat
other businesses IBM versus Mac
McDonald's versus Burger King right this
is business wars it's hosted by David
Brown he's an economics reporter
managing editor of the Texas standard so
whether you're talking about Coke versus
Pepsi to rivals and small businesses
across the country these are stories
that are like dramatic thrillers about
businesses struggling to survive in a
cutthroat world your business is pretty
exciting when you're involved in and on
a daily level but if you don't know the
stories of major business is going at it
this is the best place to find out about
the episodes are really well done I've
listened to a couple of them they're
fantastic go subscribe listen to
business wars on Apple podcast or
wherever you're listening to this
subscribe right now business Wars on
Apple podcast if you liked it leave them
a review as well business wars
definitely worth the listen again really
enjoyable stuff okay so the latest on
memo gates in the house is now voted to
release the Democratic memo so as you
recall there is the memo from
Nunez hey then there is the house
intelligence Democrat memo that is
supposed to rebut the memo from Devin
Nunez so on Monday night according to
Adam Schiff they have voted to release a
new memo that will supposedly rebuke the
earlier memo released by Republicans
last week as I mentioned I don't think
that the metal is a complete nothing
burger from Devin Nunez I also don't
think that it's a huge something burger
I don't think it's the end of the world
it is unclear to me that the memo
for example establishes what it seeks to
do which is the notion the FBI was out
to get Trump and was getting Carter page
on bad grounds in order to nail Trump I
think that's a little bit of a
conclusive finish to to the memo but I'm
gonna discuss all that in just a second
for the rest of this you're gonna have
to go over to daily wire.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you get a
subscription to daily wire that means
you get the rest of our show the rest of
michael knowles is mediocore show get
the rest of Andrew Klavan show all of
those glories you get Plus on Fridays
just be part of our mailbag we get the
annual subscription you get this the
very greatest in all beverage vessels
the leftist tiers hot or cold tumbler
unsurpassed no one can compete with it
you may have heard other hosts talk
about their mugs no this this is the
tumbler of the Gods the leftist Cheers
hot or cold tumbler check it out right
now and get the annual subscription for
99 bucks a year which is cheaper than
the monthly also if you want to listen
later for free go to iTunes SoundCloud
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
so the centerpiece of the Devon Nunez
memo was essentially the argument that
the FISA judge who granted a a warrant
on Carter page was not informed that the
centerpiece of the application the steel
dossier was funded by the Democrats that
is not super clear right it's a really
it's not it's not clear so that's in the
memo that makes that accusation but we
haven't seen the underlying application
so we don't know noonas seems to
acknowledge that a footnote to the F be
it to the FBI application suggests that
the sealed dossier was in fact a
political document
here's Nunez sort of admitting that
they've continued to leak out bits and
pieces of information to create
narratives that quite frankly have have
one thing in common they're always false
so a footnote saying that something
might be political is a far cry from
letting the American people know that
the Democrats in the Hillary campaign
paid for dirt that the FBI then used to
get a warrant on an American citizen to
spy on another campaign and it's very
it's a very dangerous precedent that was
set and what we're trying to do is just
is just get the American public to
understand admission there I mean in the
buried in that in that verbiage is the
admission that in a footnote they said
this is a political document Adam Schiff
says he doesn't know whether the FISA
judge knew the dossier was was backed by
the DNC but the judge certainly knew
that it was a political document because
it was he was mentioned if it was
mentioned in footnote as a political
document is necessary that the FBI
mentioned that it was the Democrats who
funded it or is it possible that you
know as long as the judge knows that
it's politicized then it's politicized
right I mean then we know that this is
coming from a political place here's
what Schiff had to say what Schiff said
is he said he can't go into details
until they're made public but he said
that the FBI and DOJ did disclose the
dossier was likely supported by a
political act so here's what I've been
saying all along all that has to happen
here is the president in the United
States declassifying the application and
then we can finish all of this nonsense
meanwhile they're gonna be more memos
that come out representative Jim Jordan
a guy who I think has his heart in the
right place and is it quite good
represented from Ohio he says the FBI
did not tell the FISA Court who paid for
the dossier again that may be the case
the question is is it malfeasance if
they say that the FISA warrant was was
that the rather that the Daath
was political but it didn't mention the
DNC specifically here is Jordan making
that case look more important to me is
did top people to FBI engage in behavior
they're not supposed to engage in in the
United States of America namely did they
take a disproven salacious document and
make that the basis to get a warrant a
secret warrant at a secret court on a
fellow American citizen and it sure
looks like they did and when they did it
looks like they didn't tell the court
pertinent and important information like
who paid for it like the fact that they
discontinued their relationship with
Christopher Steele the author of that
document so to me that's more important
or most important when you think about
fundamental liberties were supposed to
enjoy in the United States of America so
I agree that all of this is really
troublesome and I think that the FBI
ought to be looked at and the oversight
power obviously belongs to Congress with
that said how about releasing more
information so that we actually know
what's true and what's false because at
this point we just don't know now one of
the reasons that people are skeptical of
the FBI is because the media has come to
their defense the media now has almost a
counter effect when it defends somebody
when the media defends somebody the
American people tend to go well not sure
I actually buy it that's particularly
true when Democrats continue to maintain
that the media is unbiased in their
coverage of these issues which it
certainly is not Jay Rosen as a
professor at NYU he's been with brian
Stelter on CNN and he suggests that the
media is unbiased don't worry we have a
very politically motivated media Fox
Breitbart Infowars etc that are pushing
a dishonest narrative frankly that is
politically motivated and on the other
side we're trying to be like well we're
not on any side here are the details and
anything people's eyes glaze over and
I'm not saying that we should go in a
political direction far from it but I
think that's part of the problem is that
one side is very politically motivated
on the other side you and myself
included are trying to stick to the
facts and the facts get more and more
complicated as you know with every day
okay so the idea by the way that the
media is is only biased on the right
side is just insane obviously that is
not true in the slightest I mean you
don't believe that then Chris Matthews
is here here's what he had to say
yesterday announced applause you wanna
see full-on insanity it's Chris Matthews
suggesting any attack on Dan's blows
he's racist you understand I got up in
the morning brush my leash oh come on in
here
look at all rumpled look like garbage I
just get under it I say crap a hell of a
way to swimmin on earth if you attack
her it's racist let me explain yes I
will reserve judgement picking out
somebody from one of the coasts usually
ethnic and making them the the poster
person of the Democratic Party is old
business for the Republicans they did it
with a way back to some guy from the for
the Bronx back in the 40s they did it
they did it with Bela Abzug from West
Side of New York City they did that
their tip on the other day after Teddy
now they're doing they have Teddy Kenny
now they do it after if there was Nancy
Pelosi they'd love to get it it's sort
of they hate the Irish the Irish and the
Italians they hate those people that the
ethnic started person I love that that
now Teddy Kennedy Tip O'Neill and Nancy
Pelosi are the ethnic people in the
United States according to Chris
Matthews yeah I wonder why we can't
trust the media I just can't believe why
we can't trust the media just
astonishing
so that is the latest on memo abuse by
the way it is now clear that trumps
lawyers are telling him the right thing
he had suggested earlier a few weeks ago
that he would talk to Robert Muller the
White House lawyers are telling him not
to talk to Robert Miller this makes
perfect sense you do not want the
President of the United States falling
into a perjurer trap just because he
says stuff as an example of Trump just
saying stuff the Democrats are going
nuts because Trump yesterday in a speech
he suggested that the Democratic
reaction to the State of the Union was
actually treason like we should hang
them and everybody on the Left decided
to go completely berserk about this
right here is here's Trump making this
ridiculous case so that means they would
rather see Trump do badly
okay then our country do well that's
what it means it's very selfish and it
got to a point where I really didn't
even want to look too much during the
speech over to that side cuz honestly it
was bad energy no it was bad energy
you're up there you've got half the room
going totally crazy wild they loved
everything they want to do something
great for our country and you have the
other side even on positive news really
positive news like that they were like
death and unamerican
unamerican somebody said treasonous I
mean yeah I guess why not can we call
that treason why not why not because
it's stupid it's not treason to dislike
your speech dude hey the identification
of donald trump with america has always
bothered me it bothered me when barack
obama did it the I am America and if you
dislike me it's because he's just like
America and I got Trump doing the same
thing it's stupid it's ridiculous is
Trump joking he's clearly not joking
when he says they're unamerican when he
says that it's unamerican because
they're sitting there and listen so I
think that it's it's a particularly
American thing for them to sit when he
says that we stand for the national
anthem or for them to sit when he says
black unemployment is low I don't think
it's a great thing I think that's it's
particularly ridiculous
I think it's non-american because I
think unamerican applies to things that
are actively against the United States
and only it's against the United States
just to not stand for the president when
he's announcing something you don't want
to credit him with but he is clearly
joking when he says it's treasonous and
should I call it treason is why not
should I call juries it again he's doing
the Saturday Night Live routine this
kind of late-night comedy bit and the
entire media loses their mind he said
that these people are treason he wants
to hang the Democrats first of all if I
had five cents for every time a Democrat
suggested that I was treasonous I would
be a very wealthy man indeed the fact is
the Democrats accused Republicans of
being terrorists when it was just the
tea party protesting over spending the
the the Obama administration suggested
that it was treason
when Rush Limbaugh suggested that he
wanted Obama to fail because he didn't
like Obama's policies maybe if you had a
full list adding Dan mcLaughlin over
national view as a full list of all the
different times
Democrats have suggested that
Republicans were involved in trees and
hey how many Democrats have suggested
that the Trump campaign was involved in
treason based on allegations of
collusion with Russia that have been yet
but have yet to be proved over and over
again you hear the word treason thrown
out no of course it's not treason yes
the president shouldn't say it but he is
the president Trump's gonna say stuff
like this that is not a shock in any way
shape or form it's not a shock because
it's just dumb right it's just dumb and
we all know that it's dumb so yeah
this is a problem with electing a
president of the United States who has a
significant lack of character but it is
not a problem in the sense that you
actually does anyone who's actually
protesting Trump today think that Trump
is
you're going to initiate treason charges
does anyone think that he's going to go
round up the Democrats and throw them in
jail without habeas corpus like Abraham
Lincoln does he really think that that's
it that's command of course not of
course not so there's another case where
it's like you don't trick from seriously
you're just annoyed by the stupidity of
the comment it is a stupid comment it is
something he shouldn't have said but
people who are taking it seriously seem
to me to be doing so selectively simply
in order to in order to get what they
want from Trump which is the image of a
crazy person okay so now let's do some
things I like and then we'll shall do
some things that I hate so today things
I like so today's things I like comes
from again when I go on plane rides the
only time lately I've had a chance to
watch movies but this movie is the
foreigner but this movie was really I
would say miss publicized Toes
publicized as a Jackie Chan action flick
it is not in fact a Jackie Chan inflect
it's actually a political thriller and
the main character really is not Jackie
Chan the main character is really Pierce
Brosnan so Pierce Brosnan and who plays
the villain is is a former IRA guy who
is now a minister for the British
government in charge of sort of tamping
down violent tensions in Ireland and
there's a bombing that kills Jackie
Chan's daughter and Jackie Chan is
trying to pressure this guy into finding
the name of somebody who is of the
Bombers responsible the truth is that
Jackie Chan is almost ancillary to the
blah you could almost cut Jackie Chan
completely out of the plot and it could
just be a political potboiler about a
guy who's trying to decide whether or
not to go back to his old ways of
terrorism or whether he is trying to
root out terrorists inside his own
organization hey Jackie Chan's just
there for some cool action scenes and
there are a couple of really Jackie Chan
scenes that are great it's not full-on
kind of Jackie Chan in his youth was one
of the great physical comedians in the
history of screen I mean he's like
Buster Keaton good in terms of some of
the stuff that he does in some of his
earlier films like Shanghai noon and
such but in in this film he plays a
really disillusioned former Vietcong guy
who has decided not to be violent
anymore and has come to the UK and he's
already lost a wife and daughter and his
daughter his second daughter is killed
in a bombing I say here's a little in
the preview
[Music]
explosion rocked the city today 20,000
pounds for the names of the Bombers
that's not how we do things that's five
days in a row now what does he want
daughter was killed in the bombing mr.
Hennessy please find out the names of
the Bombers I work for the government
not terrorists you used to work for them
I don't know who the Bombers are so
Jackie Chan again the main character of
this film is Pierce Brosnan yeah I think
it's more screentime and then Jackie
Chan and he is quite good in the film
it's it's I think it's it's a very good
film that was completely played not as a
as a potboiler but as an action flick
which it really is not okay time for a
couple of quick things that I hate so
Doritos is just being mocked insanely
because they have decided to make now a
Dorito flavor brand for women designed
specifically for women in a recent
interview with Freakonomics the head of
Doritos is he's the head of a global
giant PepsiCo Indra nori she says that
quote men lick their fingers with great
Glee and when they reach the bottom of
the bag they pour the little broken
pieces into their mouths because they
don't want to lose the taste of the
flavor and the broken chips in the
bottom women would love to do the same
but they don't they don't like to crunch
too loudly in public and they don't like
to lick their fingers generously and
they don't like to pour the little
broken pieces in flavor into their
mouths and so Stephen Dubner the host of
freakanomics asked if the company is
developing male and female version of
the chips she said isn't it's not a male
and female as much as are there snacks
for women that can be designed and
packaged differently and yes we're
looking at it and we're getting ready to
launch a bunch of them soon for women
low crunch the full taste profile but
not have so much flavor stick on the
fingers and how can you put it in a
purse because women love to carry a
snack in their purse so Nui play
lead guitar in an all-girl rock band
she's one of only 27 female CEOs so is
this female empowerment because if a man
had said this this would be accused of
being sexist but she's a female so I
guess she's allowed to say it now people
were laughing at this insanely because
they're calling it Lady Doritos and just
mocking the lady Doritos so yes I guess
the way that you would have to the way
you'd have to market this is by saying
that ladies orido's have 77% the crunch
of male Doritos they don't get for every
for every 100 for every dollar you get
in Doritos crunch for males you get 77
cents of crunch for the ladies so there
is that
in other news apparently Harvard is now
going to ban single sex organizations
which is totally crazy according to
reason calm as Harvard reaffirms its ban
on single sex organizations female clubs
will become gender focused while all
male organizations will be slapped with
sanctions in May 2016 Harvard University
banned single sex clubs stating such
groups quote propagated exclusionary
values and maintained forms of privilege
the ban which bars members of single sex
organizations from leadership positions
athletic teams and scholarships targets
all single sex organizations from finals
clubs to frats well many at Harvard
champion the new policy is an antidote
to the campuses sexual assault problem
others were concerned about how the ban
would impact single sex female groups so
a bunch of female students were upset
about it and so Harvard reaffirmed the
ban on single sex organizations but
while all male groups will be
immediately punished by their choice to
remain sex exclusive all female groups
will be given up to a five year grace
period during which they could remain a
gender focus while complying with the
policy this is all stupidity it is wild
stupidity there should be male groups
there should be female groups there
should be Jewish groups there should be
Christian groups there should be Muslim
groups you should be able to form
whatever group you please to get
together with people of like mind yeah
there's a reason that sometimes guys
want to just have a guy's poker night
that's okay men are different than women
and there's a reason why women want to
have just women shopping trips or women
poker nights okay women can do stuff too
on their own the idea that men and women
have to be allowed into each other's
clubs this violates freedom of
association and it's really irritating
one of the great aspects of freedom is I
don't have to hang out with people I
don't want to hang out with it's one of
the things I enjoy most about living in
a free country
once you have people suggesting that I
have to have my group let in people from
the opposite sex because we have to
somehow show that word ha
it defeats the purpose of me having
freedom to associate and again the women
are right when they protesting they say
if we want to have an all-female safe
space let us do that well yeah they
should be able to do that people should
be able to get together with the people
they want to get together with otherwise
everything is stupid okay we will be
back here at tomorrow with more we'll
have the update on the stock market I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jessica Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing